I want to focus more
deeply on selectors.
To do this,
I've created a simple unstyled web page.
This web page showcases my top
three favorite books of all time.
If you couldn't tell,
I'm a big survival and adventure fan.
Let's try to add some
styling to this web page.
I've open the .HTML file,
and using tag selectors,
we could write some CSS that selects all
the h1 tags, H2 tags or paragraph tags.
But what if we wanted to add
style to the book summaries, but
not the site description at the top?
Using tag selectors,
we can only select all paragraph tags.
So what do we do?
Thankfully, we have a few more ways
to select HTML elements with CSS,
besides using tags.
Instead, we can use attributes.
I'm going to change my html file
to demonstrate how this works.
All right.
So now reloaded my new html
file with a few changes.
If we look at the file I've
added this ID attribute
site description to my first paragraph.
And if we look at the rest of
the paragraphs I have this class
book summary.
These two attributes
are extremely helpful.
First, because attributes help us
describe the content of the page
inside the HTML markup.
You can now clearly see that
the first paragraph on my webpage
Is my site description.
Now keep in mind,
IDs should be used sparingly.
That's because an HTML element
can only have one ID and
IDs can only be used once per page.
For example.
If I type another ID, this is not okay.
Because I'm passing two ID's,
site description and
another ID to the same element.
If I add the ID site description here,
this is also not okay.
Because now I'm using site
description in two places.
If I wanted to add an ID here
I'd need to give it another name
that has not already been used.
If I change the ID to first
book then that would be okay.
Generally, when you're
styling your page,
you'll be styling collections of
elements, not individual elements.
If you want to add the same
attribute to multiple HTML elements,
use classes instead,
like I've done here for book summaries.
Classes can be added to
multiple HTML elements.
And HTML elements can
have multiple classes.
This makes classes extremely
powerful and flexible.
You will use them constantly
as a web developer, and
most web developers
prefer classes over IDs.
Besides organization, these attributes
can be used as CSS selectors.
If I revisit my question from before,
I wanted to style my book summaries
differently than my site
description here at the top.
Using the ID and class selectors,
I can easily do that.
For book summaries they
use the class attribute.
In order to select an HTML element with
the class attribute I will type a period
followed by the name of the class.
For the site description
it uses an id attribute
in order select an HTML
element with an id attribute.
I will type of pound sign or
hash tag followed by the name of the id.
Okay, good.
Finally, allowed some quick styling
to make sure our selectors work.
Let's change the property color
to blue for our book summary.
And let's change the property color
to red for our site description.
Okay, now save and refresh and perfect.
We can see that the site description and
the book summaries are different colors.
So our selectors worked.